Real Housewives star Porsha Williams
arrested at a protest for Brianna Taylor
in Louisville Kentucky
on Tuesday I need to be with my people
with our allies side by side and
fighting for real change in justice et
has learned that the reality star was
arrested while protesting the killing of
the 26 year olds EMT who was fatally
shot by police in her apartment earlier
this year the officers involved in
Brianna's death have yet to be arrested
if you don't see yourself in what is
happening in America then you are a part
of the problem Portia and many others
gathered outside the home of Kentucky
Attorney General Daniel Cameron and a
rep for the Louisville Metro Police
Department confirms two et that Portia
was one of 87 protesters arrested quote
all were given the opportunity to leave
we're told that remaining on the
property would be unlawful and chose not
to leave the rep added that after they
refused to leave the property the
protesters were charged with
intimidating a participant in a legal
process disorderly conduct second-degree
and criminal trespass third-degree make
sure you can get right back out there
guess what you get up and you whack
yourself off and you can see you fight
the good fight the reality stars fiance
Dennis McKinley shared this video of her
arrest on Instagram Porsha's sister
Lauren Williams also shared the clip
writing in the caption she has always
been fearless you mess with her people
you mess with her it is something that
we're gonna have to dedicate ourselves
to and use every resource that we can no
matter who we are and try to invoke some
real change and yes that starts at the
post but it all starts in your everyday
life once released from custody Portia
continued her protest online sharing
this photo with Brianna's mom taken
outside the jail she captioned it with a
call for the Attorney General to arrest
the cops who killed Breanna on March
13th
Brianna was killed by Louisville Metro
police officers after they made a late
raid at the wrong address looking for
someone who had been taken into police
custody hours earlier Breanna was shot
eight times again as of today no arrests
have been made in her death Brianna's
case gained national attention after the
fetal arrest of George Floyd which
ignited protests against systemic racism
and police brutality worldwide it a woke
something in me that I knew was there I
have always had a heart for the people
it's in my blood but it ignited what was
in me fighting for real change and
justice for George Florida's family and
for the other families who have been
victims of police brutality ET spoke
with Portia in June and she explained
how George's death moved her to take
action when I watched the video when
George Floyd was murdered it really
touched me in a different way for me to
sit there and see a black man who was
completely unarmed not resisting laying
on the ground face on the pavement a
knee and his neck two other officers
laying on the applying pressure on the
rest of his body the amount of time that
he was down the every cry that he cried
out when he asked for his mother all of
that touched me in a completely
different way I'm a mother now and you
know god forbid I would have to go
through anything like that to lose a
child god forbid if I'm already gone my
child is on the ground under the knee of
a police officer who was supposed to
protect and serve down snuffing their
life out with soulless eyes so to be
able to see that it felt like I was
literally standing it felt like I was
there it really did it didn't feel like
I was just looking at a video in my
phone it felt very personal to me